[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to Thursday stream
I am Sam and today we're gonna be
streaming for International Women's Day
I joining me are Cali chastity and Hana
and yeah we're here to just have fun
appreciate the women and appreciate the
ladies that's every day in my life and
we round up about ten of us here at
GameSpot to hang out play games and have
fun so we're gonna have a rotating cast
yeah we're gonna be playing a few games
it's a really good chance if you hang
out on strings with a lot to see women
that you would normally see but you help
make the site run so mm-hmm I think
that's pretty exciting yeah we're
bringing up all the ladies from games to
represent today product social social
video editorial editorial which is me
and shout out to Jess McDonald and Lucy
James over in the a UN UK respectively
who obviously can't join us but it would
be so sick if they could all right so
let's jump into some games we are
starting today with Mario Kart 8 deluxe
because we have Kali the queen of Mario
Kart here he's gonna whoop our butts
yeah I haven't played Mario Kart in a
hot minute well that's so doing I am
probably going to come in last it's
gonna be great and it's gonna go on at
11:30 we'll have mid hug too at 12 will
have crawl and that 12:30 will have jack
box party game yes so every happen yeah
every half hour we're gonna swap out so
if you guys want to play games with us
in the very end the jack box party games
would be a good chance to jump in on the
fun mm-hmm I was let's do it do I follow
your lead
okay I am first player okay I don't know
which player I am okay I found that I am
player 3
Mariana keep it real I love Mario start
hasn't indecisive that's okay
oh my goodness I usually play this peach
for a very long time she been your mario
kart character uh he just been my main
and every Mario Kart spin-off since I
was a child mario has no speech remember
to turn off your the things because it's
really annoying when these things can we
do that now yeah I turn off rotation of
you don't want that hit minus or plus on
your controller
yeah I've been I'm in a peach main for
ever fairness I started playing her in
Super Smash Bros and then that's in the
rest is history I guess
my favorite is waluigi but my real thing
is him today
while Luigi I love waluigi things power
in the chat if you also love waluigi
then we can be friends while we used to
homie i'm waiting for him to get a game
I'm waiting for Nintendo Direct to
announce that when you a waluigi game
which is what I'm hoping that really
about no no no this is just what I'm
asking for there is no direct later yeah
there is a direct later and I just
spread the rumor that there's a waluigi
game to pressure Nintendo should be
you're here first guys GameSpot false
information game confirmed and thank you
should we start with a chill one which
we do yeah we could start chill and then
ramp it up baby park let's go what does
chill mean to you I don't know how she
already chose 156 so it's not she'll the
first so this is your accelerate and
this is your drift and or jump and then
yeah and when you turn don't forget to
drift because drifting is very important
so when you go left and right
you want a drift left right all right
yeah yeah yeah no I hang out in the chat
we are on Twitch we are in YouTube all
the places gamespot.com holler at us ask
some questions
I forgot Ouija [ __ ] I'm easy Oh cuz I
was doing through yeah but leave my
language yeah but I forgot to do the
thing I always been thinking I forgot to
do the same as well but that's okay
that's an advantage now because Kelly is
too good at this game
man it's amazing
but sorry there's gonna be a lot of
swearing I apologize Sally Prince Mario
Cart so I would only expect that it's my
brand yes we're taking it slow we are
easing into the Mario Cart pretty much
because it's just a circle I feel like
this is a good map to start on because
we have all took some time since with us
played Mario Kart regularly
I just want to and I'll just go now the
air Lance you know solid positives
just kidding no Kelly has just muscle
memory when she plays Mario Kart there's
one thing I'm confident about if there's
one thing I'm company about it's not
Mario Kart you have so many tie you say
yeah I'd like a false sense of
confidence when it comes to Mario Kart
because I used to play with my dad all
the time when I was a kid well and my
dad was just really bad at games but I
thought as a kid like oh my god that's
uncool things my dad like that's crazy
and I'm not doing so hot no mean oh my
god Bullet Bill what the hell's
controllers are also really difficult I
really I really thought that I was gonna
do better than I actually did I see
Bulgaria poorly
let's check the chat I am Yoshi that was
me
I like that uh our computers so there I
can't figure out a way to make them not
go to sleep
yeah it's they always go to sleep for
like five seconds it's like that's it's
you know yeah it's a pain if you're just
tuning in it's International Women's Day
these are the ladies of games so we have
more GameSpot ladies coming in later
we're playing multiple games were
starting off with Mario Kart 8 and I'm
doing very poorly as Mario
but please encourage me I believe in you
so think I'd like cheese land before but
I love cheese I love cheese dude it's a
very driftable map
you got a drift a lot on this map yeah
oh good
these controllers make this extremely
different I was playing on my pro
controller last night when I was trying
to practice and realize that I was trash
at this game I wasn't going so hot when
I tried with joy Khan today dick [ __ ]
this oh my god yes sorry no I don't mind
no one cares it's fine you can say
listen many times as you want it's our
day today's the day today's the day that
we drop the f-bombs that's what the day
is about right yeah definitely and wine
and chocolate and we are I talking about
things that I plan to do today respect
my family appreciation day and think
it's payday beer day isn't it excellent
I don't drink beer but I love hider week
I love I love beer like my drink of
choice
I will get to chat in a bit I'm sorry
that I've been ignoring you guys look
this takes this takes a lot of yeah I'm
it takes a lot of work to be this bad at
Mario for no as I say to Michael on
Thursdays leave in your side I believe
in myself in many aspects just not Mario
Cart
ah we'd like to have that item in first
yes bullet bill save me I hate sand well
actually yeah there we go there we go
we've done excellently memes Chasa thank
you that is a quote from the acclaimed
film Star Wars Episode two attack of
course actually embarrassing but I think
I saw it twice in theaters I definitely
saw it twice in theaters I had the
biggest crush on Hayden Christensen guys
okay so I was going to say about to
admit something really embarrassing um
I'm more about Jana Duggar that was my
favorite Star Wars movie when I was a
kid oh I could just hit at the right
time free hack rock you toad eat my ass
I'm in third place that's totally fun
I think um oh my god I laughed really
hard when I think it was way point who
tweeted what's for lunch on a random
Saturday and then Michael hi and replied
my ass I'm and I he makes me so proud it
did a shoot earlier they and that's how
we warm up top secret shoot we warm up
by saying I know fawn on YouTube says
good job GameSpot representation is good
oh hey
okay we reppin the ladies of GameSpot
and there's more ladies to come all
sorts of great ladies on the GameSpot
team from our social team from
engineering I better not miss this
because I need it so bad I'm doing some
no no I just want amazed me so bad oh
sorry sorry I'm here I'm here
yeah look also just shout out to Hana
for that race last reason I'm coming
back guys
it Hana did you get first do what I she
did do what I cannot I was too busy
telling what's are great who Greece
hollering the chat three shout out to
but I just needed a moment of silence
after that see that shuts in the chat
big man
this is already going off the rails you
know I thought that it was gonna be
because I've done a few streams of
Michael and I was like oh you know
you
and I'm also probably just really bad
let's see what we've got in the chat and
the youtubes kanye west's taro said I
love my mom can you shout out to my mom
I shout out to Kanye does mom you know
it's a Kanye West's mom yeah quiet
honest angry Gilbert says hype level 10
for the Nintendo Direct only if there's
a waluigi announcement and i don't know
but yeah i'm hype side love nintendo
directs i usually am pretty excited
about that
yeah what do you guys hope to see in the
Nintendo Direct pokemon yes come on come
on captain toad - would be nice I
personally want to see a Mario Paint
remake I don't think that they're ever
gonna do that that'd be great but you
know one can dream yeah
one fin dream that would be great Mario
Paint was revolutionary I love Mario
baby I love that game so much actually
like what are like some of your first
games that you played that made you fall
in love with games I feel like we get
that question a lot but my first copy is
so I got it several years after it was
released but it was my first console and
yeah it was just the first Super Mario
Brothers
but the first game that I got super
hyped about and wanted to spend all my
time playing whiskey burger - oh yeah
Cassie's a real big fighting game person
which is so impressive to maybe halt
mining games are so intimidating yeah I
get intimidated by fighting games as
well I love Street Fighter left tuk in
Dragonball fighters is pretty great
yeah I just wish it was easier to just
actually fight my friends right
ha no what about you what was your first
like game that you fell in love with I'm
thinking antennas 64 so yes
pokemon stadium so good the minigames
the minigames are great do we need an
n64 yeah I tried to make that happen for
extra life because I love the minigames
and put them on Stadium I oh how am i
this bed I'm still confused as to why
I'm 10 that's the first banana
I've hit and it's the first walleye that
I've hit like I've been I'm doing
something I'm doing something not as
good as you guys Tony's my enemy this is
a disaster on my behalf I'm sorry um but
peach is doing well I see her above me
no no oh my god I just don't want to be
tenth any more please say hey look I'm
11
look it's gonna be okay and I'm doing
all the tricks I'm doing all the little
Spidey tricks what kind of car did you
build me I built a bad man - f7 I'll
take it I will take it I know you guys
are all done you have to wait for me
thank you
again if you guys are just tuning in
it's International Women's Day and we
are highlighting the women of GameSpot
here by playing some Mario Kart and
losing very badly to Kali plaguey it's
just nick said no black ops 4 news here
we did announce black ops for on the
site in an article but there's you know
not a whole lot to talk about it yet I
mean I'm gonna be real I don't need any
more black ops I played all of you and I
feel like they wrapped that story
confusingly but nicely so ok before we
play again can you change my settings
cuz you were in glasses arrow answers
are we excited you're sitting so do what
you think you should turn something off
and mine was turned on I could see this
like like a way for you were doing thank
you but I am not wearing my glasses
before we do another Grand Prix which we
are going to let's check in with a chat
so we are on YouTube and twitch let's
see
Adam Prestage said you four are all
doing a great job keep it up I'm sorry
[Laughter]
person I'm sorry I suck at this game
okay maybe she's don't you wanna do you
want to build your Kart better yeah my
guy I'm gonna be a light character which
is only going to lower your speed oh oh
that's not good for me all right
let's see who else is in the chat on
periscope someone said say hi to why
right my wife Renata
hello Renata happy International Women's
Day to you thank you can you slap me I'm
shy guy cuz I don't wanna be shy anymore
I don't want to be him anymore
I I would be Daisy Daisy she's my
favorite really yeah cuz I was like she
has red hair like me I mean my hair is
more brown now but when I was a kid it
was red with age so do you sperm I'm
buying there we go
which settings
I just turned them off because I find
them annoying it's the bumpers and the
whatever your far left d-pad is I'm just
calling her Lea since she's doing well
she must have the right thing so I think
if you like motion keep it on but the
auto steering means you can't take
shortcuts which is a problem and messing
the auto accelerate I just find annoying
alright
GUP said who's who what characters are
you each playing as Ida Mario and Peach
and I am gonna be Daisy gold peach and
who is everybody here at GameSpot Hana
and me are both on the social media team
I do a lot of Facebook stuff Honda's a
lot our analytics email stuff and then
you guys are familiar with chastity and
Kali or if you're not I do a lot of
sponsored live streams but I'm most of
my stuff is on gamespot universe which
is our entertainment channel yes you
please go check it out it's awesome
yeah I'm an editor yeah you are and the
queen of Mario Kart and your Pokemon and
Pokemon yeah there's all the plushies
are you happy I have a lottery Queen all
right
you want to cut okay I think that we
should do what's on with the airport map
I like that one in circuit I like that
one all right that's a fun one fun one
Aidan Martin says on YouTube are you all
a vase in game players or just for Mario
Kart pretty much just for Mario Kart I
was actually really into racing games as
a kid yeah but I did play a lot of
racing games in the arcades growing up a
lot of Daytona you to Hana yep okay here
we go
I had an affinity for golfing games
really I guess oh my god did you like it
- yeah and then my brother lost it it
sounds awful how dare he
you know alright do you still hold that
against them shows I would let me ask
you for anything you should just be like
remember that time you've lost Mario
Golf yeah if he said to you I didn't
have an NES I had a Genesis
I had a Genesis also but I had I went
from NES to Genesis yeah I admit
super-ninja really I played the Saturn
oh oh my god I have a fellow Saturn
finna [ __ ] that I love the Saturn and I
don't care what anyone says
I've potted plant is but here we go oh I
love it
he eats things enemies think that was a
great sign yeah he'll like eight coins
for you yeah I didn't know what it was I
didn't know it was him until I activated
it oh and then I was like oh wow I moved
my chair in tandem with my drifts that
was Wow
masterful
no racing games are fun though um I do
like the forts the games like I like
looking at them it's good yeah I got my
dad the forts a Hot Wheels bundle nice
for Christmas because I got him a Xbox
one s and my brother my brother and I
split in new exit cuz my dad plays a lot
of Call of Duty so you don't say god
that is so funny
and he dammit he had like an original I
think he had like an advanced warfare
brand at Xbox was like really old like
[Music]
this is time for him to upgrade yeah
all right my dad texted me a picture of
an Xbox one he was like is this new
should I take this I was like why is it
freeze like yes I'm like yeah it's free
take it and then we can play games does
he but you guys are play no he uh I
think he wants to try but he did play a
lot of the NES games and stuff with me
when I was a kid yeah my dad and me
played laws in 64 games together my dad
refused to play any cutesy games the
only games that we played were golden I
don't do great oh man my dad says bad
Tastee until he's fishing that fishing
simulator game where you look like fish
the worst my dad was like yeah my dad
had a Simpsons mod for quake on our old
like it had like a gateway monitor our
old old PC and he had this like Simpsons
mod where you would like play as homer
and but it was in quake all right
Octus 4:13 on youtube said which retro
game consoles did you own oh yeah we
kind of addressed that but yeah I went
from NES to Genesis I borrowed my
uncle's snez but I didn't have one
smooth yeah and then I went to a Mario
and I played a lot of mario 64 and 64
and then I went to sega saturn then
playstation every single year yeah it
was also the playstation i I talked
about this a little bit I was I always
mention this to my friends but the
reason why I geared towards having a
Playstation was because a Final Fantasy
and also the marketing and I just really
was kind of appropriate to talk about
the marketing for Xbox back in the day
was very like boys if these were games
for boys I just remember like TV being
very it was just so green
oh this sudden app is so hard my
goodness I think I might shut down I did
choose this I'm sorry guys
I don't forgive me so it's okay
but yeah I did that's why I never had an
Xbox I just an ass like I didn't think
about asking for one I just liked the
PlayStation controllers better yeah oh
man
I am an Xbox Stan when it comes to the
controllers I love that what are these
shells doing here who are the enemies
are more comfortable for sure but I was
just thinking about like not even
necessarily the games that came out for
the Xbox or anything like that it was
just like the commercials right this is
like you know boys play with boys yeah a
lot of gaming commercials like actually
one of my favorite all-time gaming
articles is by Tracy Lee Anne when she
was at polygon it smelled no girls
allowed and it's just an examination of
videogame marketing starting in the 80s
and and how the demographics changed I
think it's really worth reading if
you're interested in like
why that came about because it didn't
used to be that way um especially like
even with Lego commercials like Lego
commercial used to include boys and
girls and then oh god damn it
and then they kind of switched it
because they were like oh we gotta
narrow our demographics so yeah and
there's a really good study done I think
it was called it's called pink marketing
and it was about like just how effective
or ineffective gender-based marketing
strategies are yeah I hate it I hate it
when I was a kid like I decided I didn't
like pink and it sucks cuz I actually do
like the color pink but I decided I
didn't like it because I hate it going
into like the toy aisle and see this
being told to like and like seeing is
like all of the Legos that were in
normal boxes yeah and there was like one
corner that was pink boxes I was like oh
this is what you're supposed to like
right yeah I
love Legos - oh yeah Legos are great I'm
gonna rage I was really into Sanrio as a
kid I still AM
but saying and then I eventually worked
in a Sanrio store and I was just super
annoyed by like how half the store was
pink and I was like what about Keroppi
what about badtz-maru yeah what about
cinnamon-roll what about what about
everyone else
why seriously I am really mad and like
new boxes would come and I worked at the
store and I was likewise does kitty get
everything you know who you know who
gets the shorten a stick choco cat choko
cat does get the shorten the stick but I
feel very strongly about choko cat all
right it's 11:26 we are going to be
switching over games very shortly when
we have two new players swap out so
should be I just do this one and then
see where at yes
Octus 4:13 said what games are you
looking forward to in 2018 spider-man
this is hard I'm looking forward to Red
Dead Redemption - yes that's gonna be
great I couldn't say that very well but
Red Dead Redemption - that'll be good
I'm excite about detective Pikachu are
you I couldn't tell if I mean I wrote
immediately I wrote a [ __ ] I mean that
lovely thumbnail made by Peter Brown if
you want to check that out I wrote about
how Danny DeVito is I wrote about Danny
DeVito basically so amazing Danny DeVito
no no we want Danny DeVito to be like
about how like The Sopranos like what
what he wasn't on supreme I'm thinking
of the runt
yes Danny DeVito juice character is
essentially Danny DeVito yeah and then
somebody tweeted at me Danny DeVito
Danny DeVito thinking of yours thinking
you're not thinking of the right person
cuz Danny DeVito is like a short little
goblin man and it means how it loves and
Always Sunny I mean that would love he
plays the troll in the Nightman cometh
yeah you watching
I watch a lot Always Sunny
[Music]
my goodness hey check it off Netflix but
it's on Hulu now it's all good yeah so
that's like they're somewhere to watch
it I heard that her brother bought the
whole like DVD said it was nice I can't
bring myself to pay for Hulu I have too
much to watch on Netflix i straight-up
paid for Hulu I can watch girl City
processing I love Bronson II - that's
why I paid for him I'm a huge fan of
broad city I love that show current
seasons very different from the price
it's not about the current season I like
watch the first episode and I was like
no thank was that that first episode
where like they were just super high the
entire time no watching it and they were
like really high yeah I killed a cat
yeah awful it's not fun but anyway I
like broad city generally like the first
two seasons were really good there sure
hey LaDonna whenever you feel bad just
look at me I am in 10th place I have
been consistently okay this is just
content with my middle hands are like
dying this was very bad for me anyway
you did great khali well I was beaten by
Wario who under appreciated Gameboy game
Mario World War II owes world are you
alright no no Mario Mario Land ok are we
switching nidhogg very we are going to
be switching it is 11:30 so it is time
to switch it up yeah we're gonna be
switching to nidhogg - yeah and we're
gonna swap out some people I think Han
and I are gonna trade with Shiva and
Regina that is correct yes so let's be
waiting for them if you I'll be back ok
and Sam you you can hang out we wait
gonna chill until us sauna can you grab
Regina and Shiva thank you all right so
it's International Women's Day yes
so let's shout out some ladies that we
want to give props to Malala yeah sorry
I really want all oh that's good mmm
sorry but I'm moving the mass I'm hit
keyboard it is it is not switching over
the PC the PC has fallen asleep but
let's shout out some other ladies in the
industry oh sorry I just really like
entertainment as well ladies in nursing
but this we're actually making a video
on gamespot universe today where we
shouting out women on behind the scenes
in TV and film that we're given a
spotlight to you so come on I feel bad
I can't refer her name but the woman who
edited Mad Max fury road oh yeah yeah
yes see Luke talking about Margaret
sixel yeah in this video I hated a cool
I'm a big fan of hers because she didn't
she's not ladies anyway so yeah just
talk right into the mic to get right in
there get friendly with it I'll see you
later Sam see you in a half hour Sam
will be back at 12 if you yeah so just
hang up these chairs are very high
they're welcome welcome welcome welcome
talk guys you can adjust this to your
mouth is just talk right into it all
right we've got Shiva and Regina here
Shiva tell them what you do we walk are
you so are they actually man our twitter
accounts so if you thought you were
talking to a guy on twitter it's
actually me you may have heard Shiva's
name back in the days of the lobby
awesome yes I tweet out all the all our
stories um and we also have a guy in UK
that helps me during our UK hours his
name is will so if you were talking in
the UK hours you were talking to a guy
yeah
it really depends on what our you were
tweeting or getting sassed at by our
twitter yeah so Hugh and I a tag team
and we create memes for you guys and fun
stuff and then Sam who I just replaced
in the seat she takes care of our
Twitter account on the weekends yep
Regina what do you do tuck them right
into the mine I'm a software engineer
she makes the site work yeah I make this
site well I don't I'm a she's at work
yes I helped yeah if you thought that a
guy wrote the JavaScript on the site I
did it
no all right so we are using all right
so controllers now we're switching off
of the switch ha ha ha so worth noting
nidhogg is two players so I guess we'll
just like switch off yet deaths cool
okay cool
yeah there it is there we go very cool
all right cool
all right we're on Samms account clearly
cool all right uh let's let let's let
Regina and she's because uh uh I don't
know how to give them the controls or it
you have control over it nope all right
guys we're starting and then we will
thank you yes sorry but here's the chat
if you'd like to ask anything we were
two guests up together I'm just gonna do
one G games very looking forward to in
2018 okay yeah oh you guys can answer my
per se me anybody Secret of Mana how do
you join our we're it start
yeah I'm pressing a controller anyway
I'm first I don't know man I'm second
player this game on ps4 so I don't know
how there we go there we go idiot there
you go okay
tournament it's great I got this oh
there we go for players who I'm actually
looking forward to Red Dead Redemption -
yeah whoa I didn't all right whatever it
doesn't matter nothing matters player 1
player 2 you go ahead and see your party
chasity
alright okay so that's first I'm player
to Kelly's player one oh no we're like
the same color okay I'm the one on the
left alright got it
hold on there we go
[Music]
all right what other questions we have
are you all added racing game players
are just oh we already talked about yes
but you guys can answer I'm go for it
mostly just Mario Kart yeah I played a
lot of mario kart when it was all yes I
loved Rainbow Road on the on Nintendo's
yes no not the readiest the DS yeah oh
my god yes yeah nice nicely done 64 one
oh yeah
oh cool who did you like playing us okay
I don't know like Daisy oh okay that's
you guys oh I think she's ours
yeah it'll be yeah the only okay yeah I
don't think our control you can turn our
controllers alright okay oh wait what
happened okay so give that to Regina oh
there we go
and this is for you everything's great
good luck oh dear yeah wait what good
luck have fun
do you guys you guys have played an
integral right again I got you some
slack then okay take your color take my
colors I think it'll just be like that
Oh hit next okay and ready
Oh
oh cool hair into it that's a lucky I am
changing my coffee here
oh I'm player 3 yeah it's a good look if
you're just tuning in we are celebrating
International Women's Day we are the
ladies of GameSpot and we're playing it
hug - wait Shiva which color are you I
think I'm always you know I'm purple oh
I'm not oh my god Rose it otally I'm
here okay come back here oh you didn't
see that
and we're also hanging out in the chat
if you got any questions or chris rounds
hit us up and we just want to run
YouTube the other way
oh the whoever's red does run the other
way no it's not working on you oh oh
yeah nobody keep running oh shoot okay
just keep going that way let's go let's
go so the left yes toodles
oh nice
oh my god oh my god
comment on twitch I had no idea there
was so many staff it would be good to be
introduced to more of the off-screen
team yeah that was well you'll be seeing
more than from the ladies of GameSpot we
also have Reena coming in from our
social teams and Laura and Emily oh my
god Laura's on our engineering team and
Emily is one of our God you got this you
got this you got this jump go on YouTube
James Duncan says happy International
Women's Day oh it's ign's James Duggan
thanks for hanging is James Duggan Wow
what a treat big fan this is great this
is great met John yes genius 3 is Regina
is the orange one yeah Bridgette is
going oh yeah so redo is for Gina's for
Chivas three she said remember cuz this
is a tournament alright I want to
network yeah that works out oh haha
we did it we're figuring it out oh man
this is Jason we said this is an awesome
stream hi Jason
I can't say more fun than smash
is that is that an unpopular opinion
what is that this is more fun than smash
I like their comprable I like it more
but everyone's get mad at me though it's
only I only say that because I really
don't like smash and you're you know a
lot about fighting games
I mean smash is very good at it wait
gadget got angry and he's mount
moderating the chat knee said this is
not more fun this I really don't think
they're comparable it's just an opinion
I have a very unpopular opinion very
different games completely different
game fighting games I'd rather play than
smash I really don't like oh yeah weapon
do you think we can get blue TMZ on this
is it too late yeah it's too late go
there okay
Oh oh my god it's just so hilarious it's
great oh shoot the boats tricky I was
weak I don't like the boat jump instead
of attack oh nice nice job
Oh take her down
Oh running go get her Oh No Oh final
screen gadge I know she is on Twitch
Rhino tackle says happy International
Women's Day
thanks for tuning in
wow that was brutal I liked it good job
oh I liked it I'm into that
chastity pasensya your main your my
purpose is running yeah I know but just
just so satisfying
let's keep going oh that was okay okay I
see here we go good if you're just
tuning in she I think she was led right
yes she was Santa's red Regina's pink
we're playing a trap nice isn't it hug -
all right run run run
Wow good roll oh no oh the mothers your
face business is a curbside I'm in the
business of misery Oh
[Laughter]
Oh oh my gosh oh wow wow I guess manage
if you're oh if you're constantly going
on good run yeah you're saying you
mainly okay you want a resume for it's a
much better fight than the one I was
trying to put it oh crap duck no rule
run okay so gotta stop you so I can go
take that with my little stabby thing
Daniel H on YouTube says have you girls
ever played Sega we talking about
Genesis what we talking about cuz yeah
me and Kelly to echo to Dolphin to sonic
2 sonic 2 sonic she was probably the
most perfect Genesis game Aladdin was
one one but man was it frustrating my
parents have this like Zelda clone
called goal vilius that's like I took
that written the back so shout out to
altered beast does anyone like altered
because I love that game that was a good
Genesis game the new Netflix show very
nice ultra carbon also get you you got
this go go go
I mean I'm rooting for both of you oh
it's so brutal I'm glad that the I
notice it a little less like hard so
look at are you just threw your story to
my face that's how you play that is how
you play the game there you oh wow good
roll
[Applause]
actually let's see Oh Blair Walker's
player four oh so you so it's yours yeah
okay all right so it is Cali versus
Regina for the championship of this
world I think we did single elimination
so double elimination all right battle
okay I'm I'm one yes yes question from
James Duggan hello ign's James Duggan
what are some of your favorite gaming
memories or any standout experiences
you've had in the gaming industry Shiva
you want to take this first
oh my favorite gaming memory yeah mmo's
back in college I would say that the
most fondest memories were just like
being in a guild and doing all these
good events I was a guild officer so I
like wow put together like weekly events
for a guild we did like dance offs and
everything one of the craziest things
that I like I'm so disappointed in
myself
about like when I played mmo's in
college was that there was this one
Korean MMO I think I was called cabal
and I left my character grinding while I
went to go to class so I did like some
weird thing with my keyboard where I
like alt tabbed out and so my character
was doing like the most repetitive moves
just a level up when I came back from
class and I was like two levels higher
Wow
holy moly that was fast Callie yeah I
need to get it I need to get a grip on
these controls when I play again cuz I
was just budging it let's do let's do
double elimination thank you did you
want to add any more of that story um oh
yeah
Oh about gaming industry experience - an
experiences in the gaming industry I oh
I like last year's jus DC or no last
year's e3 was super fun with the team we
were stuck in a war room for like 19
hours per day and we just went all
delirious towards the end but it was a
lot of team bonding and it was a lot of
fun and then at the end of e3 we all
took like a huge group photo in front of
her see so that was amazing
what about you back at it again our
crispy cream um what kind of like what
is your most fondest like gaming moments
or loving memories are memories or like
you like experiences in the industry I
don't have any experience in the
industry but gaming memories fondest
gaming memories was probably when I was
in college my friends and I were
finished of our programming assignment
uh-huh and then in between we would take
breaks and play Tetris attack Regina
what's throw up and attack oh thanks oh
right got it
heard you know how long have you been in
the industry or or coding coding for
over 10 years oh wow I've been here guys
event GameSpot since oh six yeah you
know who know six like selling shoes at
bands probably middle school oh where
was I
I'm although I was in high school oh oh
[Laughter]
um yeah I think so for me I've been in
the industry for a guy for so six years
now and before this I was actually doing
insurance and I was like I don't yeah
like I don't want any big change I know
I don't want to be doing this for the
rest of my life I'm not passionate about
it I know a lot of people who are but
that's just not where like my heart was
she I always loved video games so I I
got into mobile games and and now I'm
here nice and we're happy to have both
of you yeah I'm happy to be here with
you guys
yeah my favorite gaming memories um I
went to the arcade a lot with my uncle
he got me into fighting games so the
first time I played Street Fighter 2 was
at a arcade of the boardwalk and I would
just spend tons of Hoarders and so he
got me into fighting games starring with
Street Fighter 2 and then what was nice
is that he had kids and then he has a
daughter now who's like 6 or 7 years old
and I got to show her a street fighter 5
so I did kind of return the favor I was
like let's play Street Fighter you're
gonna like it
oh and she loves it and it makes me very
happy oh that's so nice yeah my life
comes full circle
yeah my sister and I have like a 10-year
gap so when I was in high school and she
was in middle school we played the
Nintendo DS yes together and we play
mario karts when that was really cute
like we just like we shared a room so
we're like on our beds just playing with
each other and just like yelling and
screaming our parents come in and
they're like wow good show like shut up
but yeah hella fun
Oh my mom's actually the first gamer in
my family oh really play Tetris and also
loadrunner my brothers and I would like
come home and with my mom after work and
then we would beg her to like play
loadrunner so that we can watch her okay
let's bring them back this way here you
go
cool all right Callie how about you uh
favorite gaming memories probably when I
was the airport and a kid saw me with my
3ds and challenged me to a Pokemon
battle that's amazing a kid challenged
you like it was like a game oh yeah and
he was like you played Pokemon and I was
like yeah I was like yeah that played
Pokemon and then we battled and I was
you remember do you remember your news
right at the time I was still so I have
I breathe headed a Pokemon and at the
time I think I didn't have that many I I
used like my mulatto shoe and my mega
Kangas gone I have like a this is some
nasty hasta Sapphire I have like a set
team for shovels and then in sudden mood
singles teams very nice oh and his
second question was any standout
experiences you've had in the gaming
industry oh sure I've been in the
industry for
five years now get back here yeah Alice
actually asked how long we were working
in the games industry so we all kind of
answered that I have been here for a
little bit over a year and then I was at
IGN for a year and then before that I
was at Discovery Channel we're doing the
Discovery News and then revision3 I
dabbled a little bit with the referee
Games team but not much I was mostly
working on a tech show called Tech dnews
and before that I was working in local
news that was a time a lot of news
experience yeah yeah I kind of
translates I've been here for a year I
was an IGN for two years i freelance
before that
nice oh my god good stop get them oh oh
wait is that a baby worm
you know the lore the lore of this game
is lost on me his loss is immediate what
is this like little nasty worm like
thinking in there I do like the
simplicity of the first nidhogg there's
no like weapon switching your character
is a lot more simple it was like more
pixelated too right yeah I like I shoot
this is like the max Scoville on YouTube
a dog 60 said happy Women's Day thank
you thank you thanks dog and also from
Oni inch Johnson oh my gosh happy
International Women's Day
thank you thanks very much did you girls
ever get into MMO games I think she was
just talking about that that was a
question from I'm just her team I'll
ragnarok online yeah shoot today I can't
no I didn't play that um me not so much
how about you Kelly
oh no I'm a Mo's not really more of a
time thing than anything else right I
don't know I guess the closest I've got
is destiny that doesn't really count at
all I think the closest I've gotten is
heroes of the storm so I can unlock that
skin profile but here's the storm as a
MOBA yeah so never mind I played I
played all these like random Korean MMO
okay you were mentioning one yeah when I
had a lot of time in like high school
and college that's the thing though
it's so time-consuming it was like
addicted to Guild Wars 1 shoot I play
that when I was 18 all the way through
like 20 me for 4 years or something
tried Guild Wars 2 but I don't know it
go worse to just didn't stick with me
and I like graduate from college and I
start running out time so it was just
bad timing
yeah yet for me was mainly a factor of
time I probably would have gotten into
Elder Scrolls online if I'd had more
time because I really liked the Elder
Scrolls oh shoot if you're just tuning
in we are celebrating International
Women's Day these are the ladies of
GameSpot we have more ladies coming
we're switching out games every half
hour so we'll have a new game shortly at
12 yeah and Wow
wait who got that one
Congrats again so good so I guess it's
me and rage it's two versus three now I
don't know which one is doing this isn't
loose again Rach it's me and Shiva oh it
is yeah okay it's it's losers bracket
what happened so just press ok when I
did play mmo's I always like played like
a warrior or element plays oh do the
thing are you uh this one's your for
ready yeah I think what's up I think
this was the yellow one oh but really
yeah I don't think so okay all right if
we'll find out right yeah which color is
which yeah press a or present us oh this
is wait you're right just this is player
this is to swear right this is player 1
getting our wires crossed here you go
this is a question from Ray Vaughan's 1x
do you do martial arts are you talking
directly to me sir I did martial arts
for a very long time I did karate I also
did kickboxing and wushu oh yeah four
years
oh nice what like when you were what age
I did cardio in high school okay cool
yeah I did kung fu when I was in Middle
School I reached all the way up to like
the seventh level and it was like a
brown belt right before my bike and then
my knee gave up come through I'm a
yellow about new American karate and a
blue belt in Filipino martial art dang
that's no don't be impressed
those are like like I spent a year
summer I spent a summer on each did you
um this is actually a really good
question for you
chassé if you have any three predictions
not really I feel like we might get one
surprise game that is gonna come out
this year's bracket okay lizards Kali
any III predictions my e3 predictions
that I might want to think about it to
be super stressed out yeah but I'm gonna
have fun it's gonna be ass one time I
predict that we're gonna have a badass
co-op stage show cuz I'm gonna be
producing it we have a lot of fun
oh wait watch it
I don't know why I get this far in
advance shoot Oh question oh dammit at
oh you're telling her some secrets now
okay I'll tell everyone it's down attack
to pick up weapons thank you oh oh I
actually have a question for our
audience like in terms of like what you
guys want to see for III like what kind
of coverage oh okay what kind of
coverage are you looking for like a
there are you are you guys more into
like the Sony press conference the
Bethesda vet press conference or xbox
like what's what's your favorite thing
to watch at e3
and I'm not sure when will they actually
love this oniy one or I liked one of the
so many one was just trailers and no one
was on this case oh yeah that was great
that's really great I don't even think
about it in terms of excitement anymore
because it's just like it's the hardest
work week of our year it is a lot of
work but we also have fun because we're
together it's super it's a great bonding
experience for us yeah doesn't like you
see all of our coverage for e3 but you
don't really see what goes on behind the
scenes it's a lot of stress a lot of
late nights we don't sleep very much we
go out to bars allow each trash a lot of
fried food this is so much fun oh my
gosh you're running the wrong way Justin
I just go just go just go oh there you
gotta keep Rob killer killer killer okay
go okay you got this
ah actually another fun fact is a
GameSpot has a post party after we're
all said and done after a three and we
all do karaoke and there are so many
amazing singer there are too many
singers at GameSpot amazing singer here
like uh Kelly did a really good baby got
back I did you baby wonderful it's like
it's last year look especially like it
was a showcase it's not like I was at a
concert it was that amazing man Justin
did some like an amazing Eminem yeah he
did I was very impressed I'm really it's
it's crazy how good all I was but
everything with her now our bosses are
incredible singers been and yeah oh my
gosh run the other way interceptor yep
ah come on in ladies I think we're
almost done with this knit hockey
adamant we got Sam marina shoes I'm
actually leaving up this oh my god just
might go on for us
[Music]
oh I could go all day I can't go go nice
my nice oh my gosh one win oh I just
want to win the losers bracket because I
can't one of the winners bracket all
right yeah thanks
Oh all right okay I think that's too
many practically yeah it's good we are
switching gaming out it is what we'll
just say wait who on the winner's
bracket last I won the first okay Kali
is the champion and Regina is better
than me and Shiva
anyway anyway wait were do you saying
we're Dana saying we're staying by to
Kali and uh let's see
and me and me all right
Sam come take my spot go ahead and uh
and talk to the people okay and Sam you
want to settle the next game I'll be
back at 12:30 cool did you guys have any
more questions for us in terms of like
how it's like working in games and then
Shree I saw nice comment I uh are you
here for your laptop thank you thank you
I saw a nice comment Regina is queen saw
that killing it also my name means Queen
it's doing I want to introduce you guys
to Rena marina she works on our Facebook
team as well our social team primarily
on Facebook and some other stuff as well
a new member to the team so we're happy
to have her here and you know celebrate
your on international I would say
so the next thing we're gonna be playing
is crawl if you guys play crawl before
no what is it
[Laughter]
no I'm just down to play anything
okay so crawl Regina has played a crawl
once once all right here we go all right
so we're gonna be fine it's pretty
simple oh I think it may or may not I
don't know
I think controllers would do something
to get out of this I'm curious okay
um so yeah crawl is basically it's a
roguelike where we beat where we hold on
I will I'm trying to talk and do an
multitask and anybody who knows me knows
I'm really bad at that I just want it
yeah I want to quit to the main menu
where's my mouse oh oh how does the main
controller wait yes yes okay thank you
see yes
all right uh Regina who is your favorite
game care sorry there you go
[Music]
Tara from final fantasy 6 oh yeah oh
good choice I included her one time in a
list oh I heard you guys talking earlier
about what your first job was or how
long you've been in the industry and I
used to write freelance write and I
include her on a list on a wall Gamescom
it was my first writing job like them
they're gone I put her on my list that's
a good choice
she's an awesome character what about
you Shiva I like Jennifer I like I like
the devious side of her yeah yeah with
my glasses so here we go squinting Oh
see need help yes the scroll yes nailed
it yeah
literally any any characters you like I
wasn't paying attention to the question
so I'm just gonna throw out Riku from
Final Fantasy oh it's just cute yeah I
would say my favorite female character
it's so hard but I really I really like
you know from Final Fantasy 10 actually
as sad as her story was I like I liked
her come back in 10 - so that's probably
my favorites I was like Lara Croft Lara
Lara Croft's Lara
so I skipped something so I wish that we
could skip this okay fine
I don't oh I'm the is it no there's a
multiplayer version of of crawl so we're
a four player so essentially the game is
that we will there's gonna be three of
us are gonna be ghosts and one person is
living and all the ghosts have to
sabotage and kill the living person to
thus become the hero living bin okay
okay sorry now you're the hero I think
we're in the right game-mode here yeah
Oh or also do you guys have some
predictions for today's antenna direct
so I feel ya we're not is this just the
beginning of an ICS is there a man was
there a menu in the beginning Shiva or
options yeah put two menu so make sure
that we are yeah apparently you have to
do the tutorial or you can't get there
something the tutorial let's see if that
works
that's like Eric from the beyond
he sounds better from beyond we just
hear you guys can't hear him on stream
but we can hear Eric in the sky
nope you have to do the tutorial wait
the vaults options Starrcade you'll
either have to do the tutorial or you
guys who play together okay we can
always go back to natal if we want to
okay oh wait oh here we go oh nice okay
here we go awesome oh okay that worked
where Who am I
I'm the red you're probably shame or
green all right which means Regina is
player one yep and I'm brain more nice
alright so a four attack as B as your
special no I don't be this guy spy your
eyes you don't wanna be skull man or
spider eyes I'm me spider eyes
Ryan Zeus are we all like in the
beginning you start off all as ghosts
maybe actually no I don't remember
we'll find out yes we shall see it's
only a MV so you're a regular attacking
your special attack and you have to
cosplay as a female gaming character
which which reminds me
oh shoot I've cosplayed oh I caught I
use actually a lot wrestling oohs moxie
Borderlands awesome oh okay oh wait yeah
I think oh yeah I go to the scammer and
here we are
oh okay I kill you okay oh do i oh I
have to take a barrel and throw it at
her okay
oh I think I just ruined everything you
so you project the barrels you can hold
and project the item that you oh oh I
could go into other room okay
Oh a spider I'm a spider
I also cosplayed as diva this past
Blizzcon yes we actually included she
been our gallery yeah
surplus cotton cosplay gallery
pullin my god I'm a spider okay
okay dang it I'm still goes
Sam have you have you lost cosplayed I
haven't when I was an all Chad they was
asked if I was gonna cosplay any league
characters and I always said I was gonna
do Leona but it has yet to it has yet to
happen if I was gonna cost play you know
Brigitta I think I could I would love to
do a Brigitta cosplay can you over
watching character but the armor is
pretty intimidating I'm not gonna lie
you like casual Brigitta forget that
forget oh shoot oh we don't know
Chester's password but we'll make up
questions for each other yeah oh yeah
you can toy do casual brietta last year
I did I know two years ago I also did
casual Farah from overwatch and that was
pretty fun weird I'm just like throwing
barrels and I'm wishing that they would
go further than they're actually going
Reena are you gonna get into cosplay I
actually just started sewing one oh your
Nana Mae and me but I'm doing an anime
character not a gaming character okay
this is a cow yeah Oh somebody killed
him yes finally who did it
I don't know who's the live I'm not
alive reading I'm gonna go so I'm so
dead
I mean I think so now what am I supposed
to do exactly I mean you want to
progress in the dungeon oh so you can
see you're the man so we are all trying
to kill you but you're trying to get
your through the dungeon trying to
progress through the dungeon where's the
door how do you pick right here no wait
ah that's a good question I think you
hmm that's not in my camp where is the
door is there another door that's it
that's why I got stopped nice oh man oh
you it wants you to go back here I think
okay oh okay yeah so you whenever you
see that we got it circle around a flame
you can like it oh she always that item
to attack the leg listen wait till the
store opens then oh there's a ninja here
oh um I don't know what I am
no I am I have possessed you're like
these little troll thingies oh my gosh I
like going in circles or I'll shoot I
actually put a good ding on your health
there though hmm
this is little me thing
[Music]
you will night okay never mind yes I
shall not pass oh my gosh
okay are you just oversized right now oh
I could shoot you no gosh no go go get
go get the star I'm just going ready
chose wait what who's the Sam go get the
meat oh yeah
what fell effective oh shoot oh my god
hey jazz you will not get me out this is
actually really fun
what I don't know how I got you can
upgrade your your bings I'm a creating
with mini guy okay what Brian ask Serena
what anime character are you cosplaying
oh yeah I never so i actually watched
recovery of an MMO junkie last season so
i'm gonna be one of the guild members i
don't know what the hell her name is
lilac she's like a cat girl yeah I don't
know anything about anime I am sorry
Gina knows a lot about anime right
that's what I hear I like anime so I
hear on the streets I don't think I know
that much about I know a lot about anime
but not a lot not I haven't watched
everything there's stuff I don't like
what's your favorite anime
yeah it goes in the shell ooh okay what
did you think of the live-action I
didn't wash it right and she like poses
so so much she'd that she couldn't I
can't bring myself to watch it
oh I'm human again okay you're still
human
we didn't die yeah we failed to kill you
my favorite anime is probably non uh-oh
is so good and it's like such a girl
power
Oh anime also I projected myself and now
a shoe my health is getting really low
I'm just I keep projecting this thing oh
my god
nice yeah how's the devil I was okay oh
shoot
nope
wait how do I grab the barrel again is
it oh I hate being the projectile blob I
don't like the projected blob I like the
mini guy a little bear trap guy oh wait
nice come for me
man is
oh my gosh
all right I'm using
I loves at the wall there we go
did you watch a full metal alchemist I
did that was really good I'm a huge the
live-action regime oh I didn't watch the
live-action Brotherhood or original
first but I didn't I think it finished
before the oh why don't I missed was
this dude what does that mean what
happened i think watching the live
action or not live-action sorry the
National Brotherhood a lot better for me
the one on that original anime the first
version of full metal I know I
understand when people don't like it but
if you watch the movies at the end it
kind of makes up for the ending what the
heck is this flying skull thing
[Music]
that doesn't
oh I'm about to die
yes oh I can like I can make this part
where all the circles why can't I do
anything I know we use all of our
chances
oh boy yes finally they did something
get back here oh there we go
boo What's Wrong boys that's your
special move oh there we go
Oh Oh God
oh no oh no oh no yes tonight yes it's
me I think you're supposed to go down
here what died you stop it
oh I transported okay Sarina what other
anime have you watched oh right now I'm
watching darling in the front however
you say it Frank's Franck's
it's a mecha anime uh-huh I'm watching a
lot of current season things right now
that have goals but also I watched a
whole lot of Naruto did you finish it no
I'm on like episode 200 it's a lot so I
used to watch bleach but this thing is
shining and I think that means I'm
supposed to do something to it but yes
No okay that was a bad idea
or am I supposed to go like this store
oh oh the neck drop okay okay
I just I've rolled into a wall I think
we also found everyone who's bad at
multitasking here yes I just keep losing
no after this what's this over here oh
shoot hmm
[Music]
Cory in the house is the best anime it's
a joke Cory in the house you mean like
like Ravens little brother yes is the
best to get out of here Alyssa said
Alyssa yeah Alyssa
Oh
all right what what anime would you
actually like to see as a live-action
movie Sailor Moon
no right now guys I don't know how to
get out of here
so this is the thing that's interesting
about this game is it's a procedurally
generate Jenny procedural generation
it's a good wrote roguelike dungeon
crawler so there's no like you can't
really like know how to get through it
but I know yeah you gotta kill us
I don't wanna yeah oh jeez but you have
to I'm just trying to find uh how do you
change oh there we go no oh yeah yeah I
tried I tried really hard sorry it's
it's me now James Tiger says what's your
most anticipated game in the works
doesn't have to be released in 2018 I
think I've been saying this for 10 years
but can getting sorry they say this year
I mean they said that I think every year
for last three years so else it happens
yes except I mean last year they made no
promises but it's just been like
speculated Oh
this stuff
[Music]
oh man I'm like concentrating so hard
did you like the new the new song for
Kingdom Hearts which I actually didn't
like it that much I'm not gonna lie
how could you say that
I know yeah probably you time it is a
hernia binky good without a cutter it's
had a car oh she came out with another
song for King Hearts 3 and I didn't like
it as much I think just maybe like give
it another listen I think initially I
didn't like like just because you're so
used to the old song yeah I think give
it like another listen like it it's
really nice
so yes flame corner for the win knit
[Laughter]
[Music]
other than that I was actually really
interested in do you try do anything
here um no no we have to move forward
this is where you buy stuff but I don't
have any gold so onward Oh gotcha onward
[Music]
you guys could try to stop me any given
time I think I shoot I want to go these
stairs I want to go up one can you it's
so hard to like figure out like I feel
like um the things for ghosts don't
they're not spawning as quick enough
yeah treasure chest right here yeah and
it's like not letting us pick it up well
it's for the human a live one he'll I
don't even need that yell because you're
I need a circle there's one nope
alright I should be able to I feel like
I should be able to go up those stairs
but maybe I have to kill you guys first
that's probably the situation yeah
that's so weird
this game's broken yeah we're just new
to it
I'm just camping in the same place Eric
what do we do god there's a closet over
here does it do anything oh no I just
got a nice chunk of health away from me
I I can't like attack anybody right now
I don't think oh there we go I think
what hurts me ow wait some who's the
green my Sheba you get out you have
things that you can make press press B I
thought it
oh you're special oh yes I did until
these things for a while
[Music]
okay all right now what
where are you guys I'm floating around
where's Rayna hiding you're not saying
yeah
oh wait I think Reena hasn't has more
specialists that she can use now home
maybe yeah you just made one and sure
you go so oh I have a thing
ah Sh
all right Sam are you still playing for
tonight so
I'm actually I did play it a little bit
doors recently even has a thingy on it
he got just now I can't go up yet
[Music]
what about this one right here Oh which
one this one I'm down here and no we
went down there are they okay
I mean there's this weird cracking
though but I can't do anything to you on
this whole I mean this store I think
there has to be like a question mark
it's just yeah yeah what's this I can
move this question why I can move this
oh wait nu nu nu slime thingies I'm
gonna die
[Music]
oh darn I'm the human don't know where
to go
okay so I can move that wait oh oh wait
no
yep use that okay
and then go yep to the right
and
this way oh do you want to switch to
jack box TV soon soon yes yeah well
definitely yeah all right so as it
appears Shiva is the winner at the
highest level being seven I'm not trying
to you know cut down your success or
anything but you are the human for
really long what I've leased it over to
Jack box then we can probably start
getting some people in the game yes yes
okay let's do that
close crawl and then so I'm gonna start
jack box I think the fourth party pack
it has fit [ __ ] three mm-hmm which is
really fun we also have jack box the
third party pack which has quit Blache
and trivia murder party oh the tree of
murder party is really fun yeah yeah so
anybody who is watching right now if you
want to join us for jack box TV games
you can we're just gonna join first and
then you can use your phone to go to the
website and type in the code and join
the game as the audience okay so you got
your phone right and then yes you can
use the yes and we have Oh what is this
I don't know how is that cancel yeah
[Laughter]
first the X this one town oh yes yeah
okay great
oh so chasity yeah so upcoming next is
chasity and Laura and Emily so as soon
as they're here we'll all do like the
musical chairs but is there anything oh
and they roll in
so we're gonna switch out now yes and
toodles Thank You Regina I'm alone hey
guys hello hello bring this to life
again bring me to life bring me to life
is this talk right into the microphone
with it sure I know I know I'm normally
on the other side of the cam all right
yeah oh yeah our new friends so Emily
let's start with you and we tell them
what you do here at GameSpot so I'm one
of the producers here I do mostly the
game tech videos so please check those
out we've got a lot of good stuff tons
of great peripheral reviews we just did
a cool video about movies that predicted
text so as a personal favor I have a big
film maker so I love that kind of stuff
so please check it out yes definitely
and we have Laura Laura tell them what
you do so I am engineering here and so I
I guess I make the site yeah thank you
that's very important and it's great to
see like people who are not normally in
front of the camera I get a chance to be
up here and then some of you guys
probably think there's only like two
girls that work at GameSpot a lot more
Angeles so now we are gonna be playing
some jack box TV games are you guys
familiar the it's like whiplash or like
Mad Libs or it's just like a fun party
game where and open up your phone to a
browser and then go to Jack Fox TV
yes do that we're gonna start the party
pack four sounds good it has pivot three
which is the new fib äj-- where
so yeah there have been four party packs
some of them like I think they usually
come with one game that's it's kind of
like a but there's usually one game
that's really good
is this the one with the t-shirts or it
was the t-shirts one is jackpots pretty
packed three which we can totally switch
into party pack three if you wanted to
do the drawings yeah but I thought the
[ __ ] is fun so basically it's like a
trivia game where you also definitely
get in yeah cuz jackbox
TV on your phone yeah yeah and we're
also taking comments and questions on
chat we're on YouTube and twitch so just
come on in and ask us some questions
say that again Eric okay oh no they made
it click click into the game there's
everybody right yeah anyway Laura so you
play a lot of board games I've played
board games with you before what's a
good one that you recommend to people
getting into board games or that enjoy
board games I guess it depends probably
on the level that people are playing at
I think a lot of people know if ticket
dried and that's usually that's a
gateway game I got in started playing
with Dominion oh so that was my gateway
game which I think it's a little bit
unique
um yeah so it just kind of depends on
where you're at yeah totally um yeah I
also like a lot of just fun games you
play with parties like a spy falls a lot
of fun and we've played a lot of code
names names always fun yeah two rooms in
a boom put in the room good before the
random people from the internet to it oh
and we got we got locked out of our way
to start over I'm not in start over
sorry sorry guys
okay so finish three go to jack box out
to you can we hide the screen first so
we can get the codes for them thank you
for the players in the room first thank
you sorry then you guys can join us yeah
this is there we go
and they'll put your name I'm gonna
leave the name that I used the last time
I played this game
DJ Sam you light into it all right cool
all right there we go we have one more
spot now you guys can totally still join
I'm gonna leave this screen up just for
a second now we are technically full but
they if you join the game you just
joined us the audience oh so so you can
continue to join yep we'll see an
audience to go up there so just leave it
for like just a minute - some people get
in before we start the game and then you
can vote for answers right isn't the
catch yes you can vote for answers and
the audience has wait so like the idea
of footage is it's trivia where
everybody has to contribute an answer
that is the wrong answer but it sounds
you see they're really quirky or it
sounds like it's right or you know and
you're the whole point is to fool the
majority of people into thinking that
your answer is the right answer or
choose any your answer one of the other
you can play to the audience you know
all right let's hit everybody's in we've
got 11 people in the audience all right
cool um oh yeah I think player 1 will
having everybody's in but yes it's me
he's cool all right let's do it
Vivek you guys excited oh yes yes feel
free to get real weird with it that's
the only thing Oh what should I play I'm
like let her play jackbox I want to see
how weird
I want to really get to know you Emily
my heart for all of you oh and anyone
else who wants to get in can be in the
audience you can vote on decoy answers
to trip up the players and you get to
take a shot at guessing the truth let's
play here we go
yep all right well the graphic design
the reduce a bit right isn't it great
[Music]
Laura's picking a category pick any
category you like hmm and for all of you
in chat watching be sure to leave some
comments and questions in the twitch
chat or the YouTube chat or periscope
blank now use your device to put it on
the other players into believing it if
you can't come up with something use the
live for me button and get a suggestion
for half the points do it now
[Music]
okay you have some cool suggestions put
them in the chat too so we enter our
lives and then we try to guess the truth
right yes a lot of fun one per one more
person I forgot what my icon is we do
marriage for what you think is the truth
[Music]
going to a funeral will be really ironic
and then you can give bonus points
someone's at you I even fun bonus points
okay let's take a look Jerry duty I
voted for this it's Wow no three
different people put in the same line
and we all fell for it yeah I gave some
bonus points - that was phone contract
Wow whoa a human lie detector good stuff
all right I'll take I got three likes
I'll take that thank you for voting for
my life all right
Emily get some therapy publish the
surprising paper that found asthma could
be treated with blank oh boy let's keep
it clean man my first thought was not so
clean here
[Music]
one of these is real which is the
concerning part a paper bag tight
underwear I know boss baby give it a
like give like 420 I got the real one
[Laughter]
oh man the two whiskey's on there so no
that's true yeah I wasn't paying
attention I didn't see that there
weren't see 420
[Laughter]
got him nice yeah
[Music]
trying to be scientific bonus baby must
be the answer
roller coasters
Wow Wow I don't understand where
everyday just takes your breath away you
know you just must be like screaming so
hard that your lungs are just working
overtime yeah yeah must be the answer
getting a lot of oxygen the real trash
is not me that's gadge so I'm not losing
that thank just to clarify actually is
to see who's actually boy here we go
[Music]
the new Fitch 3 is pretty groovy music
yeah what the graphics about it I
couldn't help myself with this one guys
that's okay we'll call it t 1400 I love
her this story I know what the answer is
I think I love na depressants nice man
fruit flavored antidepressants I mean
you're not depressed anymore vodkas a
good answer Bubblegum's too easy yeah in
lipstick the bubble comes has been
around for a really long time what's up
Eric underwear too obvious
stamps that's that's pretty good lie
I would have believed it said it was
true yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yes that is that is a real product two
people said oh I um would it be
oh I thought that might have been the
answer it's the answer okay we need to
seek this I thought it was boring to be
true and also we should buy and we
should buy something for the office yeah
Wow moving up better State job sorry yes
round two here we go bub Russ oh no I
think Bob Ross is gonna choose the bad
touch but I just said it so now you
won't blank tape in your lives now
interesting
[Music]
you got this so that's one seconds left
if you're just tuning in we're playing
fit [ __ ] 3 this is on jackbox party
pack number 4 all right let's find the
truth some dong casts a boner that's
actually really funny I just like that a
lot one was so specific I had that was
good one good answer
[Music]
worms are scary yeah maybe think of like
fingers like like I got points I didn't
do that I didn't testing I love that
donk a sorry
nice hey gage can you tell me who's
playing us who if we have anyone from
the office with their code names who's
playing is Brigitta and who's Bob Rus oh
man this might be like the first game of
the vijaya per win for you by the way no
one voted for number two that's scary
all right
there we go okay so the real chess is
gadge bub Russ has been new it cuz
you're a boss baby right and actually is
Stephen so great
[Music]
all right let's see all right pick the
truth you should have not I don't know
if it's obvious or if it's weird I don't
know I think a lot of these are weird
yeah weird I'm gonna give a like potato
I know potatoes pretty good yeah like
why would you throw a potato out the
window but I don't know people probably
do so there's a baby and a Boston Ben
probably voted for you example playing
to your audience yeah oh yeah yeah I got
you Ben again was it love is not a
potato it's raining cats and dogs
yeah that is so weird why is it raining
cow it means
yeah of course love my Wolverine in 2017
a cowboy I feel directly attacked right
now
[Music]
and no I don't actually know the answer
to this but it really could be anything
[Music]
get weird with it one more answer ok
look for the truth and who boy oh man
it's also weird
[Music]
you're doing mammogram service
[Laughter]
International Women's Day I love this
part
hashtag women's health good one oh man
yes both I gave that a like me too
I thought that was pretty good cause
backs you know your x-rays here today
calcium interesting
we like Strongbow important things is hi
drug program oh no I was gonna like
actually thought that might have been
the truth story I can't tell on stream
that's an after stream that's an after
stream story final finish here we go I
get to choose this time guys I think I
think so unless it's someone from no
2015 study by Patricia yang a PhD
student at Georgia Tech concluded that
most mammals need blank to blank hmm
my mind is so dirty whatever I'm not
gonna win sending it weird
all right cool this would be great I'm
very excited to hear you realize the two
blanks is hard yeah it is
[Music]
I changed my super PG it was so not boss
baby to live their best life that's a
good one thanks Ben okay wow this is
great
I'm gonna give a like to false baby
[Music]
funny I had to select it and I give it
give me some likes out yeah but I think
I know that I want to say the right
answer is 21 seconds to P that is just
so good job Stephen got me mm-hmm wow
that's specific
[Applause]
[Music]
it's too specific yes wow that was hyper
specific my goodness all right here's
the ranking there's not gonna choose
guys
fourth place all right cool
all right what's a list a short game in
the jack box since we only have another
I think the shortest game in the jack
box is probably quick blush okay clip
flash though yeah let's do quick lash
and then call it a day
yeah so we're switching over to quip
lash now thank you guys for tuning in if
you tuned in late we are the ladies game
spot we're celebrating International
Women's Day on Twitch and periscope and
YouTube so if you have any other
questions or comments leave them in the
chat and we will try to address them
while we're still here we're playing one
last game of quip lash there's where we
go
there's also mm trivia murder party but
I don't know if that's a flash you can
see I think whiplash is probably easier
to get into
I agree all right so we have already hit
the screen so let's put in our codes
next so this will be our final games
please join us for a nice game of quick
lash play game so I haven't played this
game so how would you describe it Sam uh
colleague mad libs
yeah with words cute graphics to bub
Russ is in let's get a gadget Stephen in
as well and then we'll open it up
all right let's share the screen all
right well my name is shortened because
say me sweetheart did not fit all so
who's gonna spell sweet I think wrong
these WS swet is cheaper said we're
gonna bring all the ladies out to close
out the stream thank you so when the
game starts coming to in and then come
on in or you can come in earlier yeah if
you guys are yeah you come in anytime so
this will be the final game of our
stream yes if you guys wanna join go
ahead get in your audience see zbm I'm
going to be two props do your device
answer them however you choose what you
type goes up against with someone else
types and everyone votes on the winner
you get points based on the percentage
of people unlike your answer and a bonus
if you get more votes than your opponent
pretty similar so it's basically
competitive mad libs where you have to
it's like whoever yes sort of wins here
a bad thing to hear after yelling
[Music]
okay ready
oh geez so we all got prompted with two
questions and we are answering them and
then we're gonna face off so sorry this
is a little boring visually for you
right now but our answers will come up
shortly James the tiger and YouTube says
got a question who is the most
inspirational woman in your life
Wow alright um think about that for a
second
Emily you got an answer my mom shout-out
to Emily's mom on International Women's
Day Sam how about you women in general
original woman in your life
Oh in my life oh jeez I think my my
cousins are all so hard-working they all
like you know a lot of them have
master's degree so I want cousins a
doctor and I never finished college that
is amazing to me I like look at them
like wow you guys inspire the crap out
of me so primary cousins but a woman in
the industry Samantha zero short fur she
did works on the game from Astra near
and she's a designer and I love her
Laura I guess I would also have to say
my mom um yeah she's just always been so
hard-working and just taking such great
care of me and my brother to my grandma
alright this needs me
Wow what the guy who used the first
toilet says it's uh this this needs a
carpet on top excellent
[Laughter]
I accidentally hit back okay guys at
first I was gonna put Birds cold cuz
he's the best whoops
Tom Hanks is pretty great the post you
guys haven't seen it highly recommend
it's good movie what's that voice he's
doing throughout the entire movie like
Washington I'm a journalist
I speak like us all the time politics
wow that's close good job shoobs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm sorry that's that's really tough for
me but I had to go with my heart yeah it
was guns
I'm sorry Lauren they're like the low
budget they had that duo with Stevie
Wonder's Oh give me just one night moon
anoche big fan what you know interesting
yeah both of those you don't see on a
registry list which do I like more
that's puts me in a precarious situation
there yeah
happy engagement but really like what
does coffee mean about a person yeah
the way that you prepare coffee does
that tell you something about their
personality maybe I'm sure there's some
article in the internet there must be
about you boy why do we not get anything
wait is it a stew Huey and Louie yeah
yeah yeah what is the H what's the up I
don't know I'm surprised I guess he's
getting a habit not the money pit H I
think press send too fast we voted for
the Hat
[Applause]
good job Laura a bad thing here's mine
oh man one of those is so scary it's
like my greatest fear somebody being
like right behind you it's just like oh
pretty scary yeah horror movies yep
scary spooky super spooky nailed it take
that GAD you're not the real chassis
just like JLo fun fact they don't have
to actually a super driver really it's
not really proper my friend did it yeah
I picked the answer that I think they
should ask ya just like at the time my
friend drove ruber they just did like a
background check on her and made sure
that her car was the right requirements
Wow that's it yeah that's really easy
yeah I don't know if it's still the same
but in the beginning
what Oh
I was like wait we all lost yes gadgets
asking me in the chat [ __ ] oh chess
the real chess was hired just saying
fine all right
Oh time to answer sorry this part is so
boring for viewers right now but we love
you guys
it's hard to think of the answers just
give you a blank box so then you're like
oh boy
man I regret I just safety clip on the
last well really I wasn't I wasn't
thinking too hard about it yeah it
started started I started out with like
a chair this answer and then it got
worse and worse I was like ah safety
quit [ __ ]
if you guys have any last questions or
comments from the chat let us know we're
on twitch and youtube and periscope and
we are wrapping up this stream with this
last game of whiplash we're waiting for
one more person left and then we're
gonna see who wins yeah there is a after
this round there is a final clip it's
like the same thing in to pitch it's
that big final answer
it's like two rounds and then like a
final where my alcoholics plus the wine
could go bad you know you have to drink
if I don't have a rack I definitely
don't have a place to cool it you know
dark dry place no contest do we know who
shoobs is that's right Qbert Oh should
be deleted name oh I thought it was goo
for a minute it usually goes as Dube got
it that's a good one ah-huh done Ching
homers
did you vote it's just so weird I had to
see I had to
it's weird y'see you know it's that I am
so it's a compliment you know that's a
condition I've never heard make I think
I'll be ready to say rebranded they're
like we need to rebrand guys what
they're both great but I'm voting for
one disclose it'd be really funny if
make a bear was next door to build a
nice alliteration there yes I do like
the alliteration
it didn't even split though I was
playing to my audience yes what weird
short it's about the same that is the
same answer faster please yes yeah I
feel like this question led you kind of
into an answer pretty Maris yeah it's
just like one sentence oh this feels
good oh I like this more of this
I feel the same way when I get short
next to the hopper a get-well card was
someone injured very clever what did you
do the binary code I did not oh it's
gonna say it seems like it's rally
she'sshe Lord sister does she's typing
oh gosh did that good job well done that
was not okay that was my safety quit by
the way doesn't even make sense I feel
betrayed by the system all right that
one's silly
I like them both though yeah mm-hmm I
good job dad she's giving me credit for
his answer you did it Ben hmm Oh God not
confused oh I love Seymour butts oh yeah
good one it's always good joke mm-hmm
mr. nice guy or Seymour butts butts if
we learn anything it's that our audience
likes a funny fact go wrong game Tech
has a lot of Easter egg butts in our
videos nice all right this is the last
batch flash which means if any of the
ladies who were here earlier want to
come in for the wrap-up she does round
up the troops we're gonna do a send-off
after this last lash oh boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
come on
yeah popul heads change the can we gonna
move to it arrived two heads we're gonna
wow that's really good girls oh right
hashtag women's and Dreamworks hit Oscar
film the body thanks so much for that I
had to vote for fierce girls only why
not
silver medal Oh silver medal okay why
wouldn't for girls ovaries nah I'll
choose three grandma Olympic silver
third favorite okay fast gargoyle owl
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah boogita
Brooke call on YouTube said GameSpot
number one live stream women's day
[Music]
alright alright and the winners let's
see I've quit blush final scores
chasidy you know the real me let's go
back to the full hole cam thank you guys
so much for tuning in a happy
International Women's Day and shout out
to all the women that inspire you and
the women out there watching and just
everybody in last word Sam
oh no just thanks guys for tuning in
everything you know be here next
Thursday playing games but today was
really special I want to thank everybody
that is here who was able to join I know
it was kind of last minute during this
together thank you thank you Eric thank
you thank you Gajan Ben and Shira from
monitoring the comments thanks for
producing the Women's International
Women's Day stream and also thank you
guys in the chat for joining us and
having fun and playing games and all
that just to a reminder we stream every
day on this channel from 11:00 to 1:00
normally and as your one of your social
media producers here at GameSpy you tell
you guys all follow our social media
channels on Facebook Twitter and all the
above happy International Women's Day
everybody we hope you have a good one
and yeah
say thanks all the ladies in your life
[Music]
you
[Music]
you